the perfect trick shot sometimes so
perfect you wonder if it's even real and
in the last video you saw us compete to
see who would make it first a real
versus CGI trick shot we all found out
that real is the only way to do trick
shot this is a Redemption art that's
what the people want to see they want to
see visual effects rise to Supremacy my
Wally future is not dead the people want
the Wally future and I'm here to deliver
and once again like the last video we
have a three trick Gauntlet that each of
us must go through and we've upped the
ante this time in this round we have a
whole new set of trick shots and the
first one starts right here with a seven
bounce ping pong shot first bounce is
here off the wall Apple box Off the Wall
Apple box sixth bounce pancake and
seventh in the cup our second shot the
slap stick slap that ball challenge the
Calgary Stampede that's better we'll do
that one Jake must take a stance right
here and slap said tennis ball up the
ramp off the ramp and lands perfectly
back in the bucket here for the final
trick shot we have this cup in the
middle of the studio and we're gonna
bounce a golf ball from up there off the
ground and that golf ball is going to
have to land in the cup down the stove
pipe hit the button on the light and
then the red light's gonna go off if
that red light goes off on you you've
lost once again like the last video we
have the same penalty rule we are not
allowed to say the words dude or perfect
if you do you must come over here and
make a classic beer pong shot before you
can continue the gauntlet
yeah you were so close to beating me in
the last round had you not said those
words that many times you might have won
I'm laughing because you don't know what
I have in store a whole new system built
from the ground up
[Music]
last time I had some issues I had to
type some numbers in like an old crony
and it wasn't working very well for me
so this time I've devised a perfect
system that gives me visual feedback of
the trajectory and the strength of the
shop you see that little yellow line
right there that's a velocity Vector
that is pointing me in the direction and
magnitude of my shot and it's all
controlled right here baby in control
and that will be the Difference Maker
good luck see that hand should really
mean that good luck are you doing a
thing right now no I'm trying to get him
out no I'm honestly saying good luck you
want me to have good luck yeah all right
I want you to have
you can't see it can you all right let's
go
congestion's ready ready
three two one go
immediate disadvantage that's ridiculous
I just got to get it at the right angle
just like last time it's there it is
I mean dude there's someone that's gonna
take me forever let's lock out the world
and just be perfect
I'm going to the winds right away this
time I'm not playing around so as soon
as it hits this I'm turning on the wind
I need the X direction direction of one
keyframe this let's see how this works
okay
[Music]
right you're right you're right blinders
it's like baseball you know this is just
a probability game the number of shots
you take keep swinging the bat
eventually the game can change on you oh
built here Fox One bounce box two bounce
I hit so much so much much more advanced
than what I was working with the first
go-round I need a little more bounce out
of my boy
come on look at the ark get close
dialing I feel like a freaking surgeon
dude oh get out of here dude I heard it
I heard it you said direct me where
which one's me
Frank
I'm panicking help me this is dead table
you're giving me a dead table Harvey
pick up the balls
where's my he's got four people picking
up his balls no one's touching my balls
this is a dead table
the amount of shots that he gets off is
insane okay let's 2.5 let's just go
crazy and just see what happens
it's so close
oh I just need a little bit more oh you
know what I'm gonna do the wind yes what
am I doing blow it come on okay okay
okay right there right here we change
the wind baby The Winds of Change are
among us I hit it with a little bit
what have I done oh I did the thing
oh I did the thing oh I did the freaking
thing there's one thing you can do in
Houdini that I don't understand where I
click it and then all my three values
turn into one and I don't know what I
just did and I can't undo it
this is literally the one thing that
could not have happened I'm closing I'm
shutting it down oh you're shutting it
open shutting it down I genuinely don't
know what I how to do that I had this
issue literally yesterday I fat fingered
it leave a comment if you know what the
heck just happened and how to fix it
please it would mean the movement the
world to me
oh it's just a matter of chance
oh my God it never stops hurting okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
[Music]
gotta try to hit that second box lower
I've rimmed it five times
oh come on baby
please give me something
give me the love I deserve
the magic it's giving me the tragic
brother what is going on I'm gonna dive
deeper
hold on a minute
hold on a minute something's going on
this is an issue with a collider brother
this is a spiked drink I mean this is an
inside job this is it this is the
problem look I can't believe I didn't
see this earlier display look watch this
watch this it's a shut cup there's a lid
on it
oh my God
it lives off
Lids off
[Music]
the car baby one two three four five six
seven yes dude come on it's a new oh you
good dude
oh
oops damn ditches
Trick Shot Two here's the thing
that was the hardest one for me I think
by a large margin the fact that he's
still struggling and tells me that I'm
in his head a little bit
okay so here as we can see we've got a
similar situation we have our initial
velocity all I need to do is change this
location this little controller right
here and I can literally dial in
the exact angle that I want I think this
should be fairly simple especially given
the bucket side so you can see it's a
huge bucket and right here I have a ball
velocity multiplier the more I increase
this the stronger the shot of the ball
I've got control over the balls bounce
the psych bounce the ramp bounce and of
course my good old friend the wind as
you can see my tools have just truly
evolved
[Music]
oh come on
it's got to hit every bounce
that might be it
brother
[Music]
come on baby
thank you
oh we are so close the fact that it is
making a difference is encouraging what
if you just blew a little wind I know
people are gonna say oh you can't do
without win and I'm gonna say watch this
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time for me to get serious we're
getting win baby it's winter time
hi you might notice how hard I'm
concentrating right now and that's
because I'm honing in and I'm sending
out
on today's sponsor Squarespace you see
whether you're a trickshotter like me a
restaurant owner an entrepreneur or a
small business owner of any kind
Squarespace has what you need to make a
beautiful website in 2023 they start by
offering a Full Slate of beautiful
award-winning templates for you to build
your website off of and don't worry if
you've never designed a website for
yourself you see Squarespace has 24 7
award-winning customer service available
for you whenever you need it Squarespace
also has best in-game analytics which
allow you to better understand who's
coming to your site how they're using it
and how you can make improvements to it
over time that's a wonderful feature so
if you're interested in making sure that
your small business makes it just like
these trick shots head on over to
squarespace.com corridorcrew and you'll
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
Corridor crew or just click the link in
the description below for 10 off
this is why I love this game because you
if you just keep swinging your luck can
change like that he's talking in the
middle of the I know I would never do
that okay okay win win win win win win
okay it's got the win the guy has wind I
don't know if wind
I'll give you a little gust
s
come on
come on I'm so bad at that oh you suck
elbows
there you go Zen baby Christian would
you like to verify oh you already got it
did you get it you just got it
just got it
damn short stick man it's about
Evolution all right this is showing
development of character and I can use
the ones I have used the ones this
is my staple shot and I want to show the
world that I don't need the wind the
wind needs me
and considering Where We Are
I think I could do another one
okay for the last one we've got to
launch the ball from the top so I'm
gonna use these visualizers here and I'm
actually going to extend the length of
the Velocity visualizer check that out
so now I can see exactly the direction
that it's aimed in it's very very
helpful and I'm just gonna slightly
tweak there we go dial it in so that
should be like right on where it needs
to be this might be the same issue as
the last time where we just gotta dial
it in a little bit
so freaking
oh thank you oh my gosh why am I so bad
at this dude
you gotta do too yeah dude
this is definitely the most physical one
call me
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys ready all right three two one
continue
[Music]
oh my gosh this one I've got the idea I
just need to figure out the ball
it's part of the inconsistency of the
floor
a little spacey today this is impossible
get them in the freaking thing man
[Applause]
I said Colby
[Music]
come on
no no no no no don't do that
entering the Mainframe
okay where are we at so we're okay dude
we're so freaking close that was a dude
this table's dead
in the thing I'm never gonna get invited
to another party in my life can I just
Sim it yes let's go enter the Mainframe
I'm gonna just listen listen just fine
this may be what I need oh my God
literally it's literally right there
it's so close it's really hard maybe I
throw them like a ping pong ball oh yeah
there we go that helps and literally if
he just gets lucky
it's over for me
[Music]
you're gonna have to rely on the wins I
will not I will not
you're gonna go back I will go down in
flames before I rely on the wins
oh you can punch it in easily with the
win I will not use the wins it's your
hubris
oh
hahaha
let's go
ah Victory this is a sad day for
Humanity that's it baby he's probably
cocky enough to allow me Redemption
shots and I'm going to test him on that
oh
hey Jordan yes I bet you can't stand the
fact that if you give me five Redemption
shots
I won't make it I'll give you a six oh
it's on you
dude
I'm scared
[Music]
if I gave him an extra one he makes it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Can't Hold Us Down anymore baby this is
not perfect in any way
look at him just so prideful
it feels pretty good how do you think I
felt with the Smash tournament
when Dean won oh when Jordan Allen oh my
God you can act you can trick shots he
can smash he can render
it's too powerful he must be stopped
I've dreamed of this day
congratulations good game I'm really
impressed thanks and today today you're
the perfect dude
but as we saw
things don't last forever
enjoy it yeah enjoy it while it's yours
we'll be back the Winds of Change are
blowing aren't they
I swear on all that is perfect and all
that is dude
I will get revenge I will Revenge and
avenge Humanity
I'm gonna assume you go ahead the Wally
position yeah
[Music]
this is what I wanted this is great now
he'll he'll rest on his laurels in his
Walling position and I'll go and do some
training uh can I get a food tube anyone
Jordan
oh hey surprise